what makes me good at my job is also
what makes me bad at life
this is maybe more than you bargained
for
our next guest does interviewed everyone
it's a Cathedral of poor that's a little
offensive you're a very fascinating
person how do you connect with people
I'm just so curious about what takes
someone to that place
why people do the things that they do
the question I get asked most often is
how do you not get angry with some of
these people especially the ones who are
sort of spewing hate if people see like
your attempt to wrestle intimacies from
them that's never going to go well I
think also at some point we think maybe
the other person's got it figured out
and I haven't your former wife said
there's nothing real about you Jimmy
Savile he also said something about
insincerity being your specialty this
girl glad you brought that up
I remember it vividly first of all
I neglected my personal life to focus on
achieving professional success the price
was paid by those nearest and dearest to
me when did you get that feedback I saw
my relationships as a life support
system for my kind of work self instead
of the other way around saying to my
wife well this is what I do I did a lot
of great segments just by being
available at a moment's notice I just
think oh this isn't going well so it
became a bit of an impact is it
something that comes with a cost and is
it something you want to change
foreign
starts I have a small favor to ask from
you two months ago 74 of people that
watch this channel didn't subscribe
we're now down to 69 my goal is 50 so if
you've ever liked any of the videos
we've posted if you like this channel
can you do me a quick favor and hit the
Subscribe button it helps this channel
more than you know and the bigger the
channel gets as you've seen the bigger
the guests get thank you and enjoy this
episode
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're a very fascinating person thank
you
and I've
you know I've as I've read through your
story I read your autobiography as well
I was trying to understand
what I needed to understand about your
earliest experiences to really
understand the man that you are today
the the interesting personality you have
and the trajectory you went and took in
your life
so please enlighten me what what are the
most pertinent things that I need to
know about your earliest years to
understand you oh my goodness we could I
could I spent two hours answering that
question on its own I don't know how
interesting it would be I'll try and
give you a brief answer I like the long
answers oh do you yeah well first of all
my
um parents are my mum's British my dad's
American
they are both
um in in different respects from free
thinkers that they they grew up in the
60s and they Embrace aspects of The
Counter Culture they regarded their own
parents as being in certain respects so
limited and cloistered and and and so my
mum joined a vso volunteer service
overseas to get experience of life in
Africa my dad joined the Peace Corps he
would have been probably enlisted to
serve in Vietnam and he didn't want to
do that so he went to teach in Africa as
well and that's where they met so I was
raised
um I was born in Singapore where they
were teaching my brother was born in in
Uganda where um where they were teaching
at that time my older brother but then
we said they settled in London and and
so growing up I was conscious of
of them as people who who really
encouraged us to open our minds and
maybe you know it was a 99 positive like
one percent I think like a lot of people
you know people use this term social
justice Warriors right as a form of
judgment about overly do-gooding like
there's an element of I don't tend to
use that term because I sort of I saw
it's become it's been weaponized but I
suppose in a sense my parents were kind
of social justice Warriors like they
were very much encouraging me to
challenge or us to challenge racism
where we saw it to challenge sexism to
be uh open to new experiences not to
fall into easy judgments about other
cultures and other countries and other
people
and and and I only say the one percent
sometimes that could be inflected with a
little bit of a sense of superiority and
I talk a bit about that in my book a
slight feeling that we weren't really
like uh quite like other people you know
other people were maybe not quite as
smart or not quite as literary you know
and I don't I don't you know I strive
not to endorse whatever is in me remains
in me of that I try to unpack and
eradicate but nevertheless that's the
way looking back on it that's something
that I see and pick up on my dad's a
writer novelist my mum is a you know
after teaching uh My dad became a very
successful literary novelist and travel
writer my mum went on to become a radio
producer and worked for the BBC World
Service which is for those who don't
know that's the service that broadcasts
all over the world and it's it's a bit
like Radio 4 but broadcast this tiny
language it's extraordinary institution
it sort of representing someone is the
best of the BBC but
um so I was growing up sort of aware
that we we were a family that loved
books and and loved reading and you know
we watched TV and listen to pop music
and did the normal things but I think
underneath it was a feeling that
to really count in life
um you should be a literary writer like
that was that was without me fully maybe
acknowledging it that was underneath
this thing that you should really I
think it's still my dad probably feels
that like he's very supportive of me and
my TV making but he's like Lou you
thought have you thought about writing
another book no you're you know you
you've got time you've got the talent
you can I I don't want to push you into
this but Lou you should think about
writing a book that's a great idea for a
book you know that kind of thing anyway
so that all of that was under underlying
my attitude to life then they sent me
off to
um School primary school I'm gonna have
to I mean you wanted a long answer this
is maybe more than you bargained for I
suppose alongside that is the the
influence of friends and and and you
know I can start and so the
countervailing impulses of growing up in
the 70s and 80s in South London and
being exposed to funny creative people
and my friendship Group which who you
know some of them have gone on to work
in so civilian quote unquote lives as
you know restaurateurs or or you know
music other stuff but but saliently were
uh Adam Buxton Joe Cornish and another
friend Zach Sandler who were super
creative Adam and Joe went on to have
their own TV show and I was conscious of
falling in with a little group Amelia of
of um like-minded kids who are very
funny
really into movies TV and that was where
I suppose
I began to feel
that there was well you know I don't
want to oh in hindsight it's attempting
to um
sort of read back read back what I do
now into that but I just know that that
friendship group was very important to
me and maybe counteracted some of the
more because I was academic I was I was
I did really well at school
I feel I could just go on and on should
I go should I keep going I just listen
here because the other part of it was
that I was um I was quite an anxious
child so I I worried about everything
and uh I I would think about things that
were on the horizon like when I was five
or six years old I remember fixating you
know there were various things that came
and went that really worried me but one
was um the idea of maypole dancing which
was a big I don't know if it's still
like in state primaries
um at that time
every May holiday like you would do
maypole dancing
it's an Old English or maybe British
tradition where there's a big poll I
think it's like a fertility right you
know it's a touch of wicker man about it
you know it's a enormous kind of Mast a
poll like maybe like like a totem pole
almost like so 20 feet high and then
there's ribbons around it and as
children you would skip round it and you
would sort of braid the ribbons together
to form nice patterns and I remember
seeing them doing it in primary school
and things like that looks really hard
and I'm gonna have to do that next year
and I don't know how I'm going to do it
and just I remember being preoccupied
with how am I going to learn how to do
that I only mentioned that as an example
like there were other things like just
reading before I could read I remember
seeing my older brother reading and
thinking I don't know how you do that
and just getting very worried about it
so in general my I'm someone who is PR I
know everyone worries but I just feel as
though that feeling of worry and anxiety
was quite a strong background note and
sometimes I would control my anxiety not
consciously but again looking back by
working hard like by by sort of it's
just sort of becoming almost like super
focused on academic work and
um
and as a result I did very well in
school and
um
you know like those people who look back
and say like well I was a [ __ ] up in
school I was the opposite like I didn't
always
you know I would get in trouble like and
sometimes I was regarded as especially
when I was younger 12 13 is a disruptive
element because I was also quite cheeky
and sometimes tried to communicate and
connect with people via teasing right
which is I don't know if that's a common
it's quite a British thing in a way
there's certainly a big thing in my
family was
what's now called banths right and
sometimes I try and do bands with my
teacher and then it wouldn't go well and
so but but in general which is confusing
like regarding being regarded as a black
sheep in class or a disruptive person in
class and then
um but then also getting in trouble they
said like it's fine for you to mess
about and get in trouble and then you do
the homework and you're fine but you're
a bad influence on the other kids I used
to get told that you're a bad influence
on your I was like that's not true at
all like if anything my friends were
just as naughty and were leading me
astray but nevertheless because I could
go home and then become sort of
organized and focus on my work
I gotta I got for a brief period I got
labeled as the Troublemaker anyway going
through school
I I sort of um there's a little the load
stars for my um sort of sense of who I
was and how I would progress in life
such as it is I mean I was never that
tactical but as I went
as I went through school I thought well
I'm pretty good academically I guess
I'll just do well in exams and stuff and
then see what happens and meanwhile with
my friends we'd be seeing movies I got
into rap music in the late 80s and so
were dressed like a sort of hip-hop nerd
I was smoking quite a lot of weed but
still studying this was sort of again
age 16 17. but it never really
interfered with my with my work I went
on to Oxford
and then
having done well at Oxford
um left University and and at that point
was like well what happens now that was
when it felt like okay now I have no
longer
really got a clear path does that make
sense yeah you know I think if you
if you are if you're academic if you
find academic work not easy but you find
that you do well at it because it's not
easy but you apply yourself then you do
well
then sometimes life can be a weird
um bump in the road like real life it's
something like well where are the exams
because I know I can do those you know
what do I do now so for a while I
thought maybe I would be
like a professor or an academic or
something
but then something in me told me that
wasn't quite right
so then the rest of life is another
story but I hope that sort of answers
your questions about those different um
those different uh sources of of of how
I sorts you know my whatever it's
personality and interests one of the
things that really stood out to me in
that answer was your your early
relationship with work you said you used
to work hard to kind of
suppress or kind of distract yourself
from the anxiety of life is that
accurate well what it is is um
well I worried about things in general
and um
you know one of those worries was
homework or doing well in in school like
another worry was
getting on with my peer group but uh in
so far as I can I could control those
sources of anxiety like you know you I
work is actually relatively
straightforward like in terms of how do
I
get more you know how do I attempt to
relate to people better well that's
that's kind of hard it's like mysterious
but how do I do well at these
assignments are being given
um then you just sit down and do them
um until you get it right and and
you know a lot of these things are
aren't are subconscious like I'm not
thinking like oh how can I control my
anxiety but I would just find that
I I if exams are coming up I'd get super
anxious and um and I don't mean to
pathologize it like I've never been
diagnosed with an anxiety disorder I've
just slightly worry prone and as it
happens I've become less worry prone
as I've grown up and it may be that
there were other things going on you
know in my family life who knows
um in you know my parents marriage
wasn't always happy they subsequently
divorced there are other things that
probably were going on
that were stressful but for whatever
reason I found that all without almost
without meaning to I I would I took my
studies
uh very seriously I have to sort of
slightly check myself when I say this
because I do I'm also aware that I've
looked back at some of my reports having
kind of got quite attached to this
Narrative of myself
a sort of super SWOT right super
studious
and I've looked at some of my old report
cards and some of them are
are especially when I'm six or seven
sort of say um
you know Louie's a pleasure to have in
class but I it sometimes it would be
nice if you would let others pupils
speak he he enjoys the sound of his own
voice kind of thing which is very
apropos for this podcast probably you
know and like so so I I had a sort of
rambunctious side and almost in Social
settings my mum tells a story
essentially in my book but of how when I
was about five or six I would come home
I'd be really sad I'd be like
I don't know I don't think I don't like
school anymore and she'd sort of think
well Louie's obviously not getting on
well at school I need to talk to his
teacher and she went into
to class
and um and talk to the teachers and said
you understand Louie's very sensitive
he's a very sensitive young man
as I said would have been maybe five or
six seven years old and the teachers
were like really yes he's a very
sensitive like you just be mindful that
you know things you can say might hurt
his feelings something like that and
they were like struggling to recognize
her description of me
and then on the way out of course she
passed the customer could see through
one of the glass windows in the door and
I was running along the desktops or
doing a dance on top of a desk in other
words like it was almost like in the
setting itself I was a wild child
and and just as you're running a muck
but also I had like his doubling like
then I go home and be kind of be
worrying about small which I think is
probably still true of me in some ways
that I have a um
I have that sort of disruptive trickster
impulse alongside a certain
um
a certain sensitivity is that defense
mechanism or a a way to I don't know
survive in a social setting or is that
the truth is who I am and I think you
know I could say oh well I was a younger
child and
my parents found me funny and I wanted
to perform and I I wanted my dad
to you know I wanted to get my the
approval of my parents by being silly
but the fact is is who knows like I just
know that
you know things like your sense of humor
or your inclination to to be cheeky
that's just always been in me
you know and you know I'm slightly wary
of attempting to to sort of um unpick
where that comes from because I just
know that's that's that's always been in
me
the relationship with work I I think
even for myself I learned my
relationship with work at a very young
age and I I think I developed quite an
unhealthy relationship with work at the
expense of other things that matter in
life yeah me too I think I can relate to
that and that's what I was trying to
understand is like when did you where
did your relationship with work come
from on one hand I was guessing maybe
it's from his father who was very you
know insistent on in being an
intellectual is a is Success Louis or is
it from the distraction of from anxiety
and from the social thing where you
could be successful at exams because you
were good at that so you double down
I think it was all of the above like my
dad's got both my parents have work
ethics that border on this sort of being
over the top my dad
I would you know he's a he's a as I said
he's a writer and at the weekends
like he didn't really take weekends off
like certainly
Saturdays you would often be writing and
Sunday mornings he was often writing and
and he he's an extraordinary I wanted to
give both my parents a shout out see I'm
my parents were um
were basically first generation
University educated came from very much
not at the high table of life and
and so for my dad
to to sort of become a wealthy literary
writer it's kind of an amazing thing
that he did you know in the world of
it's one thing to be a popular novelist
that's hard anyway to be a a novelist or
travel writer who's extremely successful
and you know
sold hundreds of thousands of millions
of books
just uh without any leg up in life is an
amazing thing and um
uh I wonder if I've ever told him that I
hope I have anyway he'll listen to this
probably because he he follows my
he follows my uh career with interest so
some of that I would have taken on board
just through osmosis of seeing that
likewise
um my mum being super studious going to
Oxford she grew up in tooting you know
and and her her sense of
so self-belief or her sense of her own
destiny whatever it was and in her small
you know peer group of kids who were
educated at a state school and then
through her own hard work and the
support of her teachers going to Oxford
you know in the 60s as a woman that was
extremely unusual so that would that was
in the air but in the end and my older
brother who was very studious and the
other thing just to reflect on is that I
saw my brother as
the more brilliant child like he was
to the way I saw it at the time was more
effortlessly brilliant like or sort of
child prodigy material you know and I
thought I was just kind of a sort of
irrelevant bit of after birth that you
know trailed around after him and so
when I noticed that I was getting fairly
good results
um when I was sort of 11 12
it didn't feel particularly impressive
like it felt like well I guess I could I
can do well if I work hard it's not like
I'm kind of brilliant like my older
brother
um but I think when I you know again in
hindsight I think mainly what I see is
um
is a sense that
I just felt like this was something I
had to do it wasn't a choice and I even
later on when I was at University I
sometimes used to worry that um I wonder
if I'm missing out you know people say
it's the best years of your life and you
should be hanging you should be just
going wild having fun and I did a you
know some of that but I was also
conscious of
like maybe I'm missing out by working by
studying too hard that's what I read
into your story of University was that I
wrote I actually wrote in my notes
worked his ass off at Oxford on the
point of affection this is also
something I probably didn't learn from
my parents if I'm honest I still call my
parents by their first names
um did they encourage you to do that yes
yeah I just didn't I didn't learn
affection and actually you know even
growing up at 10 years old when one of
my friends turned to me and went you're
my best friend my body like
because the the idea that I was
someone's best friend made me cringe and
I had this I think I had this like
emotional intimacy affection issue
growing up although
I think being a best friend is something
you show but don't say yeah it's a bit
creepy you're my best friend I'm never
feeling stressed when a friend said that
to me and I'm thinking because you then
you feel like you say oh you're my best
friend and then it feels a bit
inauthentic yeah yeah yeah yes yeah like
do it don't say it do what I mean yeah
yeah I love you it didn't feel necessary
to say yeah exactly
but what is what did you learn about
affection at a young age
I I feel really lucky that my parents
um
I feel as though they were you know they
worked hard like I had a working mum my
dad was as I say had a huge drive to be
successful but I I always felt like the
love that they had for me was
just taken as read like I never
questioned it do you know what I mean in
a way that felt positive and even though
you know I think there's a tendency or a
Temptation nowadays to look back and
and be thinking about things that could
have been otherwise and I think you know
parts of that therapy culture really
valid but
there's also a sense in which um
you can focus on negative stuff and
I'm not sure
at a certain point how how healthy or
helpful it is and and so for me
I never kind of questioned
but the love the love that they they had
for me and it it was it was never the
case that I felt I was kind of um
seeking their approval like I remember
friends at school saying well my
my parents say if I do well in common
entrance they're going to get me a watch
and I remember thinking that's quite
weird you know or my parents never I
never felt like they needed to be I that
I was in any sense doing like working
hard for them and if they took an
interest
that was kind of a bonus but I didn't
rush to show them like I've got all A's
or you know I was I came first in all
the exams or whatever I wouldn't really
talk to them about it like that was just
something that I did for me what about
emotional expression I think that's
something that we learn how to say like
I love you and to hug and to be to touch
and ah because you said bance yeah like
I've my
humor is really important I say such a
kind of what though because that's so
dead it's cringe I mean my kids voices
in my head but you know humor is a very
important way of communicating you know
humor is really
I often think you know in terms of how I
see Life
that's why I'm worrying I sound a bit
humorless but anyway how I see life is
like humor is like the missing dimension
in terms of it's almost it can't really
be expressed but
uh we we shared a sense of humor as a
family and so we would make each other
laugh and
so teasing was important I it'll
um just not take yourself too seriously
my parents
I would say
um like I respected them I would have I
see how my kids behaved towards me and
I'm that classic thing like God if I did
that to my parents that would not have
gone well it's not that I think of them
being especially strict I didn't feel
they were at the time but I wouldn't
have dared to um
I don't know like
uh there was a sense of
of them having boundaries that I would
respect and observe they slide also they
slightly cheated because we went to
boarding school me and my brother age
13. so those difficult teenage years of
sort of 13 to 18 or 13 to 17
they were part-timing it and if Mum and
Dad if you're listening I'm sorry about
that's what it is right I mean it was
weekly boarding and they got me in the
holidays but other than that they were
getting me half of Saturday and Sunday
so I've got kids who are teenagers and
you know that that's where like the the
a lot of the conflict kicks in so uh
when I look back at
how I related to my parents
there were times when
um it felt like they didn't get me or
they would be too hard on me or the
mixed messages because
they were sort of one hand being
free-spirited and saying like if you
want to smoke some spliff Louie like
that's fine just be careful you don't
get caught like kind of thing or other
times you'd be like how dare you you're
going out there you know what are you
doing like it was like well which part
of the are we being are you being
counter-cultural kind of dudes or are
you going to be like Victorian Parents
like which is it but in general
um I kind of I kind of got it I kind of
got I got I kind of got the um
you know that it was about there was a
foundation of love and approval that
wasn't you know was unconditional and
and
I think if I had anything
to sort of and it's a sort of reflect
reflect or approach them for not
repropriate so reflection things that in
hindsight could have been different
it's the feeling that because they were
work focused
and also because their relationship was
complicated
sometimes it felt like
um
that me and my brother and I were
slightly a side effect like we weren't
and which again I could spin that as a
positive actually like there was a sort
of a level of us being autonomous you
know up we had whatever the opposite of
helicopter appearances
they we slightly had that like they were
like okay cool you know you do you and
and and
um
and I think again that can be I kind of
quite grateful in some ways for that
but
um you know they have their own thing
going on it reminds me of something Tim
Grover said which I've repeated a few
times he says he used to train Michael
Jordan and uh Kobe Bryant and he was I
spoke to him on this podcast when we did
the LA run and he said that sometimes an
event that happens in our life or
something that happens can create our
Brilliance it can be responsible in the
case of that kind of void of
Independence your parents create create
someone that works and that goes and
gets stuff and that's able to travel and
be an island
um but it also can create our dark side
like the same event creates our
Brilliance but also our dark side so my
question to you is from that particular
experience of having that Independence
and feeling a bit like you were
side thing in their lives what was then
the the dark side I can see the upside
against the upside for me it felt like
the upside you were saying is the
independence yeah yeah and that's right
yeah yeah there'd be in a space to grow
and become your own person and not feel
that you're especially kicking against
anything but license to follow your own
interests I think that's all positive I
think
um
uh what is that that look I think in
general
what you know I've said this and
probably someone else said it as well
that you know what you think maybe your
disability is also your super
empowerment exactly and I think
um uh uh
I think that I in
I think
I've struggled with intimacy sometimes
my you know and and
I think I
you know in terms of relationship
building in in my private life
like it's a running joke between me and
my wife like that she's extremely sort
of emotionally acute and that I'm
slightly the opposite which is kind of
weird when you think about my job which
hinges on
supposedly being sort of maybe
emotionally or psychologically
perceptive but it's almost as though but
I see in my mum as well like my mum
having worked at the BBC
went into therapy became a relationship
counselor
and it's funny because
um my mum also finds it difficult
sometimes to to fully inhabit
her emotions if it doesn't sound an odd
thing to say I and I'm going to probably
regret saying that but
let's make it about me and I think with
me I think
um
yeah I don't always find
intimacy easy like it's it it's so so I
sort of I've I experienced like a lot of
the times my work
is a license to be intimate without
consequences like to get to a bit like
what you're doing now like you talk to
people
someone in a prison you know who's been
sentenced to ten life sentences he's
like okay how does that feel
so what is what's life like and and then
kind of get getting whatever happens to
be all the work I've done in some sense
is about attempting to peel layers back
and and and see inside someone's psyche
and then get on a plane and fly off and
go home and live my normal life
almost did a less intimate plane of
existence
and um so clearly you know and the other
joke I've made over the years is like
what makes me good at my job is also
what makes me bad at life so so for me
it's I think and I think you if you ask
my friends they might say you know be
like oh yeah you know Louie's a good guy
I hope they would say that but but
they'd also might say like he's a little
bit absent like he's a little bit
um
I don't feel I'm an especially attentive
or present friend and and you know I'm
not
you know some people are really gifted
at friendship like they they like really
they're there and they think about they
make arrangements and I don't make
really I'm not very good at Social
Arrangements all these sort of boring
things that are the qualities that are
really the stuff of life like
um just getting together reaching out
are you okay it's been a while since I
saw you I wanted to let's meet up let's
which in general this is a cross
generalization but I think women are
slightly better at than men and I think
that's been one of the many gifts my
wife has given me
is actually involving me
in life like in a just a normal sort of
neurotypical way whereas my tendency
would be to sort of disappear into my
slightly in cell-like Shell you know of
of kind of in a metaphorical shed of
kind of
counting the joke in making my book is
like you know separating my collection
of screws and nails into their different
jars you know what I mean like that for
me is like that you know a lot of guys
will be like yeah that sounds like
heaven to have two hours to organize my
shed you know and not realize that
you're missing out on the tapestry of
life so I plead guilty to whatever that
is
maybe that's just being a man I can I
can relate to it's funny I was having
this conversation yesterday with my
friends where they're all saying yes
Steve doesn't like to socialize you know
I I would rather sit upstairs for seven
days on my own working than like if
someone said to me you meet all these
wonderful people on this podcast and you
and it's such a wasted opportunity that
you don't text me hey let's go for a
coffee yeah and it's just outside of my
nature my nature is to sit alone on my
laptop and work yeah and so again my
girlfriend my partner is the opposite
yeah so she's dragging me and so it's
quite a common Dynamic you know not
bragging two nights ago I was a GQ Man
of the Year I thank you Applause thank
you
um uh I was one of the honorees and um
so there was a like there was a banquet
like a posh dinner catered by Heston
Blumenthal
and you know stormzy was going to be
their most Salah Leah Williamson the
footballer he get him in fact so it's
not just men now it turns out uh
extraordinary list of like Andrew
Garfield an extraordinary list of
incredible people and it wasn't even an
awards Bank it wasn't even like the
baftas like where you sit and sit
through the speeches and then at half
past ten when you're starving hungry and
quite tired you sit down eat your food
this was like a banquet banquet where
you just sit around and have a delicious
meal and then a few people pop up and
say a few words between starter and the
main course
suicide and it wasn't even that it was
like maybe a couple hundred people like
quite small as these things go but the
point is is before on the evening of
I was like I don't want to go
and I said I knew I had to go but I said
to Nancy my wife I was like I am not
feeling this she's like what is it I
said I just I can't
I can't you know I don't know I just
feel really anxious and she's like but
you're not even giving a speech are you
you know because sometimes it's that
like what if we win and I have to give a
speech or or you're worrying about
whether you're going to win tonight I
knew I was an honoree and I knew I
wasn't going to say any I wasn't going
to have to give a speech
and it was just the idea of of having to
talk to people like oh and in a
relatively high high wattage settings so
you think like I don't want to be
wandering around like a blithering idiot
so there's a sort of little stress that
sits alongside that but there was no
real reason on paper why I shouldn't
have been thinking wow this is going to
be amazing this is going to be a night I
remember my whole life you know and I
attempted to adjust my mindset you know
using kind of Paul McKenna like or Yuri
Geller like you know just visualize
think about what this is this is going
to be no one's expecting anything of you
this is a chance to sit down with some
amazing people and have fun but
nevertheless for the first kind of hour
I was there just thinking
I kept just sighing
and Nancy was like what's the matter so
I think that's just for whatever I think
that's in me it's probably in a lot a
lot of people and um you just deal with
it but that you know why why should that
be the case I don't really know why is
it something that comes with a cost and
is it something you want to change
if you're being really honest if I could
dial down
I think sometimes I think I have changed
it actually is the first thing to say
because there were times in my life
where I said no to things
just because I thought that's going to
be a bit like you know I did the maypole
dancing in the end and it went fine I
did learn this will surprise you but I
did learn how to read and you know
despite all the anxiety I had about
doing that and so and then as life went
on I think there were times when I said
no to things opportunities
which probably just because the idea I
was asked to go on David Letterman's
chat show um
when it was on CBS This would have been
in around 2001 and I said no because I
thought that's just going to make me
anxious and looking back on it I
probably
wish I'd done that why would that make
you anxious I find the chat show
experience or not especially I mean I've
done it a few times and as life goes on
it seems you know the idea of public
speaking or you know when I first got
into TV
it it was like why am I doing this this
is not me like this is not what I was
cut out for this is not something that I
aspire to do and it sounds really
you know the whole notion of it
feel some intimidating and and just a
bad fit
and and nevertheless I knew that you
know just briefly like I was working in
magazines as a um as a journalist in New
York and um that's I I aspired to be a
a TV writer partly as a way of sort of
avoiding comparison
with my dad not directly but I suppose
that was in my mind was like I wanna
write and be creative but I know I'll
never write books
you know I didn't feel like I wrote
when I wrote it didn't feel especially
as though it came as easily as I as it
should
you know it's hard when your dad
like I relate to people with famous
parents like you know people like you
know Jacob Dillon yeah who's Bob Dylan's
son I don't know why I reached for that
comparison but Jacob Dylan that track
one headlight do you remember that one
no okay for people who know the joke you
know that's a great track was a huge
International hit but his dad's Bob
Dylan that's a painful maybe not painful
but that's an extraordinary Legacy to be
born into and in a related way like I
was conscious of my dad his name as a
writer really meant something and that
it was
um that if I was to attempt to write
something
it was going to be a case of very likely
kind of falling short at least in my own
mind but the idea of writing in
television was was less
I thought that would set would wouldn't
invite the same comparisons Plus
I used to watch TV and I liked TV and
there was something about the Democratic
kind of nature of Television the fact
that everyone watches TV I thought well
that's a way of working in a medium that
will connect with people and so it was
in the mid 90s TV was
uh in a kind of a mini Golden Age The
Simpsons was on Seinfeld was on friends
was just about to come on
that there were all these amazing TV
shows Larry Sanders was another one did
you want to connect with people you
studied history at Oxford and as someone
that is appears to be a bit of an
introvert by Nature from what you said
about yourself I have a duality where
I'm partly shy and introverted and then
partly outgoing and an extrovert so with
your writing and with the TV writing was
your and with the magazine writing I
knew you did some extent to um spy and
was it Metro in Boston Metro in San Jose
San Jose California was your was your
objective and the thing that you found
fulfillment in your work from was that
connecting with people
or was it just I don't I think I
connected with people not to sound
um you know oxymoronic or whatever it is
no tautologists by connecting with
people like in other words like I always
find I do my best connecting
sounds a bit weird yeah face to face I
mean maybe at one level but in the end I
think I was just trying to do good work
and get approval like maybe more than
connection like just trying to sort of
get an A at work do you know what I mean
like so I would feel good and think like
oh I got 10 out of 10 on my article or
on my piece of writing my film review
and then if people said to me
that was really good that was like
getting it you know like you've got a
good review or whatever you know people
say like you you did a good job then it
it was maybe a way of
um it's just a little
it's just a little uh Spurt of whatever
that is like just kind of pleasure you
know worthiness What a Feeling worth you
know I don't wanna I I think I've got a
healthy relatively healthy sense of
self-esteem but nevertheless
I I think I I I whether I require it I
enjoy
you know getting I got I got a series
out at the moment this isn't my attempt
to segue into the promotional portion of
this interview but
nevertheless here we are I got a um I've
got a series out at the moment on
iPlayer called Louis through interviews
and we had one that went out a few days
ago where I interviewed Bear Grylls an
alumnus of this very podcast I've
listened to your interview with him by
the way thank you in preparation and um
and when it went out
for whatever reason I think because I
thought it was a good show and I hoped
it would I hoped it would get a good
reception I was on um I thought I'm
gonna go on Twitter and see what people
were saying
and it was surprisingly quiet
and then I felt a bit like
um
okay now I'm gonna I'll try at Louis
through I'll try hashtag bear gryll I
tried a few different Search terms
and then I suddenly I had a vision of my
you know you get a vision of yourself
like oh I've become that grubby guy kind
of like it's sort of sad it's like
trying to fish for fish for approval in
the vast swamp of the twitterverse right
casting my line and nothing much is
coming back and I thought well and then
one that came back I looked at it and it
said just watched Louis through his
interview with Bear Grylls wow it was
hella boring and I was like I just
caught a boot
and then I was like well that's what you
get
and by the way it isn't boring the point
I was trying to get to was
um then a couple days later I got a
review great review in the times just
pointing out all the things about it
that I knew to be really really good it
was sort of the perfect review you know
Rave saying like this is fresh it's new
it's different it's fun it's
entertaining it's revealing and I felt
really good and then one level's like
because before that the first three
episodes I hadn't really checked Twitter
I thought I'm not that guy anymore I
don't really care like I make the shows
and I know they're good and the ones
that aren't so good I know none of these
is is a clunker they're all solid and
and then here and then and then I
suddenly thought oh I went back to I
regressed into being the needy sort of
um the needy insecure person which is
you know and and that guy is always
there by the way I think a lot of people
could probably relate to that which
doesn't it doesn't mean you know which
which is um which is fine by the way but
I suppose to to your point
um or you know in all the kind of work
in the work I do is not like is it an
urge to connect like it's an urge to do
good work and then it's nice for that to
be recognized and as much as I
I could I'd like to pretend that
I don't really care whether people like
it or not I do care actually do you know
what's funny is my team are very honest
with me and we're in the car the other
day and I believe it was Holly Holly and
my team who might be upstairs now and I
said um we were talking about Louie's
coming on the podcast I said oh he's got
the new series out where he interviews
people I turned to I think it was hot it
might be someone else so sorry if it's
someone else um I turned to them and
said how is it because they'd seen it
before me and they went
it's actually really good oh nice that's
what they said to me and they would be
and they would be so honest with me they
went it's actually really good and then
they explained you know why it was good
because I mean here's my things like
that actually like isn't it it's
actually like it's actually really good
but you see when I because I've I'm a
very glass half empty kind of guy is
with respect to praise yeah so what I'm
hearing there is it's surprising yeah I
mean like because I'm here is that a
surprisingly in which case why would
that be surprising I could I think I can
assert why it would be surprising
um I think that
the generation Holly is in they don't
watch
um shows like that on BBC One typically
and especially two but BBC Two sorry bit
on the BBC should I say yeah
um but that's what I got from it is her
generation who are like 22 23 who spend
a lot of time on like Tick Tock and
Instagram and these other platforms I
think
um it was I was actually quite surprised
and I think that's probably true and
also I think in my world
if I'm going to talk about stuff you
know there's a troll in all of us right
and and and in general it's more
enjoyable to talk about stuff and dunk
on stuff because it's [ __ ] right like I
I know that sounds horrible and I think
you're right and you're oversimplifying
I think you're right there's a little
problem especially in the in the
journalistic or the in in sort of media
Village
is like did you see it yeah yeah that
was rubbish wasn't it and there's a sort
of reassuring feeling of like yeah yeah
let's all let's all give it a kicking
yeah so so when you acknowledge that
something's good you're someone's saying
like I'm gonna grudgingly acknowledge
that that was good I think you're
correct you know that's a bit yeah yeah
I think pretty much everything
especially when because we probably
consider ourselves working in the media
industry sure so for the team to go it's
actually really good yeah um and then
she went on to explain things aren't
that good they're not I mean most things
are fine yeah but most things are like
only about as good as they need to be
and I mean especially in the interview
format like how many other ways can you
can create an interview format that is
original and inspiring yeah and that's
also what I got from her was like she
was talking to me about the way the
format was constructed yeah I think we
pushed things forward a little bit like
it's not a paradigm shift like we
haven't completely flipped the script as
they used to say in hip-hop circles but
it is you know we worked on the grammar
we tried to do things a little
differently so we created a for one of a
better term format you know that allowed
for elements of
um actuality just being silly having fun
or being in live settings where the
unexpected could happen but also bits of
um
uh conversation that would be going to
places that were quite deep So yeah
thank you for that and that that that's
that's thank you for passing that on
TV I I read when you were 18 is I think
maybe 16.
um if someone had said to you that you
would end up in TV you would have you
would have been sort of perplexed at how
that would have the steps that it would
have taken to get you definitely true
you're you're in San Jose I believe at
the time
um is that where spy was the magazine no
I was so awesome just to rewind and I
also want to mention one other thing
which is because we talked a little bit
about studying and
and I feel as though whatever that is
that work ethic has stood me in good
stead but I don't feel that that's I
often think there's
you know very understandable
misconception about the level of
importance of academic work you know
that whole stay in school kids and
you know we were talking I think off off
Mike about Mr Beast the YouTuber and you
know the media landscape we're in now
it would just it's just simply not
correct to say that oh the path lies
through academic work right and I was
talking to my cousin Justin Thoreau
oddly enough he says Thoreau who's an
actor he's a director a writer he wrote
Tropic Thunder Iron Man 2 he's been in
he's also like high profile Hollywood
actor I interviewed him for my podcast
I'm not trying to plug that'll be weird
to plug one part podcast on another
podcast but he and he he was like
someone who struggled in the academic
setting like he had ADHD he um flunked
out of a school he went to another
school where they recognized his special
needs but the point is that I sort of
think so many I think we under there's a
tendency to undervalue those parts of
of
um of life that could that lead to
success that that exists I mean maybe
you maybe I'm sort of out of line here
because it sounds like you are all over
this but those parts of like the parts
of life that help me become whoever I am
part of its academic part of it was
almost inimical to academic success it
was the part that was free-spirited and
naughty and that was bunking off school
and seeing movies and and um or or get
getting me in trouble and and and and
whatever that is and it's hard to really
bottle it and know quite what it is you
know there's something that I struggle
sometimes with over discipline right and
and or a sense of like doing well in
controlled settings but actually it's
that you need the yin and the Yang of
both and and when I went out and did
stuff that was successful on TV like
working during my first segments at a
show called TV Nation having been hired
by Michael Moore when I was 23
partly like a work ethic you know doing
preparation and being you know turning
up on time as they say is like 90
percent
of the battle but actually then being
just sort of a la allowing those
creative juices sort of to cut you know
whatever that mysterious quality of
um humor and connectivity just be being
silly and disruptive like those are
really valuable they say don't they they
say Conformity is great to succeed in
school but it's not great to succeed in
life maybe that's what it is you kind of
need to be to unconform once you get out
you sort of do and I think and I want to
come back to your question but but I do
think that that's also you know three or
four years ago I started a company and
there's a part of me that's overly
um
so overly conventional you know and and
as a result seeks out unconvention in my
work and that's positive you know
because it means I love spending time
with people who feel like they give free
reign to the darkest weirdest impulses
that I think to an extent we all share
but keep repressed you know whatever
those happen to be people involved in
sex work or or people involved in
religious cults or hate groups and and
that's all my stocking trade is talking
to those people because I feel as though
I kind of get it I I understand that
though that that's part of the full
compliment as horrible as it might sound
to say like we all have like
unacknowledged and secret
um impulses that you know we we have
sort of civilized
oh oh uh in you know and and kept and
repressed into into you know in we've
inhibited them into our souls so that we
can function and not go to be sent to
prison or whatever I'll be canceled but
um for me like I I sort of I I do it to
a fault to the point where I worked at
the BBC in-house in BBC Studios
just because I sort of liked the idea of
the structure like I'm a company man
going to the factory and you know
building my TV
programs but not owning them and because
I just thought you know and I like going
to the Kent I used to love working at TV
Center because it felt like going to the
Factory and then eating at the TV Center
canteen you know it just felt felt like
comfortable you know my my granddad
worked at the London water board his
whole life he had one job that he
started when he was 18 and and finished
when he was whatever 65 you know to
somebody said those were the times but
that temperament is slightly in me the
whole time when when he left they gave
him
um some a box of Cutlery you know that
was the you know you've worked here for
47 years here's your your silverware in
a walnut case it was on a it was in a
private place like not pride of play it
wasn't on the mental piece but you
usually you should look at it that's
what Grandpa got when he worked at the
Metropolitan water board for 47 years
you know he was a reverence it like and
it was only used for special occasions
and there's a little bit of that in me
and so when I finally went outside the
BBC and set up a company three or four
years ago I'm sure most of your
listeners probably have their own many
of them not most but many of them will
have their own companies or will be
fully cognizant of what it takes to make
it in the sort of the world of of free
market and Entrepreneurship but for me
that was just absolutely not my lane and
it was my wife who pushed me to do it
and so
that was a case of me needing to break
out of whatever I was doing and say you
know what whatever you think that is
you're risky or mysterious or
um you know a bit a spivvy you know like
just a little judgment like oh I don't
want to be one of the Yuppie guys like
we just had an IPO I've just got my
first Maserati like that because I I'm
antagon you know I'm completely that
whole mindset I feel like I'm alienating
maybe some of your listeners like it's
not my mindset like I'm just like I I
almost
valorize the opposite of that you know
to an it's probably
um an extent that's uh so faintly
unhealthy like like I don't want to be
the guy I don't want a flash car I don't
want to flash clothes I don't want
anything I want to be anti-flash right
like my watch you can see this my wife
was saying to me last night
um you know maybe time for a new watch
this is a Casio whatever that one is
it's a f91w these cost like 10 pounds 15
pounds you can get them at Argos have
you ever seen that watch before I have
Andrew Tate on the way here a podcast
you know who Andrew is yeah what's your
anyway so Andrew feels like he's that
guy reduced to its quintessence where
he's like if one of his catchphrases was
um people say why have you got a you
know Green Bugatti
did you know this Meme and what does he
say to them he says um well he says what
college I say to them what color is your
Bugatti
right that's him in a nutshell is like
unapologetically troll like ostentatious
displays of wealth and arrogance right
so I'm the anti-tate you can put that on
my you put that on my gravestone the
anti-tate
so I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] about
your Bugatti I think it's embarrassing
that you have one but you know fine you
know and that's kind of a joke like
that's I my point really is that that's
something I need to keep an eye on you
know because actually ostentatious
almost like ostentatious humility is its
own poison like like why are you so
wedded to the idea of having a [ __ ]
watch by the way it's not a [ __ ] watch
it's completely reliable and it's I've
never had it the only thing that goes on
it is the strap so I've got one that's
got a you can replace the strap after
about five years the strap goes I've got
two of these I'm not bragging
I've got one I've got my I've got my
spare one in case I can't find this one
anyway last time my wife said it might
be time for a new watch I've got to
embrace I'm trying to lean into being
the guy
that isn't showing off about what a lack
of what a not show off he is you think
I've lost the thread I haven't the point
I'm getting to is that um so I needed to
start a company and not because it's
oddly infantilizing after a while like
there's nothing there's nothing cool
about
making like hundreds of hours of TV and
and not owning any of it right that's
just me being a little bit of a chump
and partly that's you know there's a
quid pro quo I suppose like well you
don't get stressed you turn up you're
making things for a public broadcaster
you're getting a decent salary for sure
but people would say like what you know
everyone else he said who do you work
for it's like well I'm in BBC I'm on
contract I work from contract to
contract three years at a time
like really you don't have your own
company like no why not like you know
because everyone else does like Jamie
Oliver or Hugh Fernley witting stall or
or you know whoever you care to mention
any presenter bear gryll of any
longevity
um would would be making their own shows
you know it's it is it's a no-brainer
and I was like I guess I just I'm fine
doing my I'm a creature of habit you
know that was sort of what I've just so
fine I don't want to mess around with it
and then having done it three or four
years ago like yeah I probably should
have should have done it a bit earlier
but it it's so so it's that thing of um
the point which is now landing on the
point sounds a bit banal is that you can
sort of get in being a creature of habit
being sort of embracing or whatever that
you know your own sense of self as
um risk averse and
um conventional sometimes you know I
needed to challenge myself
in order to discover that there was a
you know a world out there that was sort
of more creative more lucrative more fun
more adventurous that's happened a few
times in your life where you've kind of
taken a leap into the unknown which is
actually quite surprising having you
know described yourself as a creature of
comfort even habit have habits sorry
yeah um
but maybe you've comfort as well
although you know but habit is really
what I meant yeah creature inhabit
because like because I was reading about
when you made the transition from being
a writer to a TV presenter and
I I remember writing some quotes about
how
um how like there was one about feeling
like an imposter a little bit to some
degree and getting on that plane to go
and interview these Christians once
Michael Moore had sort of um put you
front and center and thinking what the
[ __ ] am I doing here yeah that was I
remember it vividly it's extraordinary
as you go through life so much
disappears but there are times when you
realize you're at this Mo sort of
momentous moment I suppose often it's
high stress moments
um which which is really revealing isn't
it because actually risk avoidance you
know that that almost like God my mind's
whizzing now but that bent of my idea
like the greatest happiness you know in
philosophy there's a utilitarian ideal
that's supposed to be the bed the metric
for how you judge whether an action is
good or not and it's like the greatest
will it cause the greatest happiness of
the greatest number of people but then
if you unpack then like well what is
happiness like and what actually how do
you measure it and how do you measure is
it happiness in the moment is it
happiness as it's recollected over time
is it um a happiness that you know
um you can uh that will spread to other
people or you know it will exist for a
hundred years uh and and so actually
there's a there's a sense of fear and
discomfort that will subsequently lead
to a sense of of of of Triumph or
self-satisfaction
you know is it happiness is it I don't
know like that fear is such a such a
blunt instrument for attempting to
measure reality and um and in general
fear which you would equate with
unhappiness
can very often be what ends up creating
the conditions for real achievement and
I I I I remember Sitting on This Plane
having been given a job by Michael Moore
as a presenter on you know TV Nation it
was a network TV show on NBC one of the
within three networks in America I was
23 I I was as I say awkward in every
apparent way disqualified for being a
correspondent on a network TV show
I was in I was having I was in the union
like you know as probably still the case
but definitely then
um these TV shows were unionized to an
extent in America further than they
would be in the UK so I would be I was
in The Writers Guild of America uh as a
result of being hired and so they were
required to fly me business class like I
don't think I'd ever been in business
class and somehow that contributed to my
imposter syndrome my sense like I
shouldn't really be here I remember
sitting there thinking like this is all
kinds of wrong like I don't know what
I'm doing here I don't know why they
think I'm qualified to do this and
nevertheless this is what's happening
and and I was that there was a segment
that uh was about you know TV nation was
a kind of satirical
fact-based comedy show where you went
out and slightly made fun of people with
to prove a political point or to sort of
make some sort of social point so I was
interviewing religious cults about when
the end of the world was going to happen
so so like slightly cheeky
um irreverent take on religious
fanaticism or religious weirdness so
he's like I wanted to know so when will
the world end is it on a Tuesday how can
I get prepared and I would sort of white
in a wide-eyed way oh no like will there
be you know another spaceships going to
land and what will the aliens look like
but I was just incredibly conscious of
of thinking like why have I been given
this huge
um it felt like a big slab of pressure
and and sort of License to fail very
publicly and very embarrassingly and and
I also knew I wasn't
you know but I'm also wasn't so
disconnected from reality that I didn't
think like well it's a huge opportunity
like my girlfriend at the time was very
supportive and he's like you know you
you should you you can do this Louis
like you're you're really good with
people and
and
um and and you know don't don't worry
like you you can you've got this you can
handle it
when you try to talk yourself out of it
I was um it wasn't like I ever thought
I um
I I won't do it like there's no question
for like I'm gonna do it like I have to
do it but I I sort of didn't want to do
it does that make sense has that been
typical of your life where you know
you've got to do it but it feels kind of
painful and anxious as you approach the
challenge even like with starting your
own company oh yeah I think so like
there's times when
you know I suppose that's where the
worker thick part fits in or whatever
like that part of
if if you commit to doing something like
I'm very I hate to let people down like
if I commit to doing something
um or turning up on time or
I still struggle with that part like
especially as you're in the when you're
in the public eye or you're in demand
and people write and ask for things I
still you know will you come to our
school and give a talk or I don't I
I I'm a very agreeable in that sort of
technical sense I'm very inclined
to agree to do things and that can get
you in trouble because you find you're
over I I find I over agree and make
unrealistic commitments like oh that'll
be fine and then I'll do that and then
I'll do that and then you look at it and
you're like there's just no way on Earth
I can do all of these things so I try
and ring fence my commitment levels but
that's not easy so but in a positive way
um that sense of like feeling like I
need to show up having agreed to do it
having been offered it a um an
opportunity even though it might sound
enormously stressful like I would never
I think this may be a world in which
I never got into TV I don't know quite
what I did end up doing the thing that
it makes me reflect on is the extent to
which we're conditioned and groomed into
behaviors that can be healthy or
unhealthy or positive or not positive
and I think that's the part of the
libertarian ethos that I have a huge
well among others that have a huge issue
with it's like oh just let people be
themselves people need help to fulfill
their
potential right that idea that oh you
know you can pull yourself up by the
bootstraps like I with all the
advantages I had of like a first-rate
private education supportive parents
even I like didn't see myself as someone
who would have various kinds of success
I didn't feel that that was in me for
whatever reason but other along the way
people among Michael Moore
um people at the BBC who then
commissioned me to do my own series off
the back of TV Nation when I got
commissioned to Weird Weekends my wife
Nancy other people along the way
have sort of seen things in me that I
didn't see in myself even this interview
Series going out at the moment
I I never it sounds awful I never
aspired to have like a TV interview
series like it was something that would
be mentioned from time to time and I
would say like that's not really me you
know I like going out like my my comfort
like my happy place
really is
in terms of TV like oh go and be in a
prison for two weeks and film the
inmates or go to a mental hospital or go
to a
um a brothel like I made a film about a
brothel and just hang out there for two
or three weeks and just be a FL that
that to me is it sounds awful but that's
that's like pure Bliss like work wise
but the idea of oh we'll have a formal
sit-down interview and you'll talk to
someone famous who probably only has a
couple of hours for you and then we'll
piece it all together and do shoot I I
never thought like that's really
something I want to do but Patrick
Hollander is then in charge of BBC Two
had listened to my podcast and said like
I really think this would work so I'm
not this exactly but there's a there's a
there's a TV show that takes aspects of
this that could exist that would you
know involve you talking to people and I
and I remember you were thinking like oh
that would that must have been exciting
like someone's saying like I wanted to
do it this TV format involves those
partly Chat Show partly documentary I
just thought I didn't think like that's
something I'll never do I just think
like
I just felt very blank about it and
that's horrible like people are going to
listen to this and throw up in their
cars but I just thought that sounds so
stressful
I'm not sure if I really want to do that
what I made myself the point is I made
myself do it because I had a team around
me who I knew expected me to do it and
at some level I had enough sense to
recognize that it was an opportunity
these people that have seen things in
you that you maybe couldn't at the time
have seen in yourself or seen roles for
you that you maybe at the time couldn't
have seen for yourself Michael Moore
Nancy and then people at the BBC that
you mentioned
are you aware of what they're seeing in
you
now in hindsight what they say yeah I
think so and I think in with with a bit
of time I've been able to appreciate
um
that I know it sounds
sort of glib and maybe even false modest
but to appreciate that I have something
to offer
um what is that
well
um it makes people feel uncomfortable
when you're asking these questions no no
I'm fine with it like because I feel as
I can analyze it
um with the benefit of 25 years of doing
it I think it's something to do with
like a little bit of intelligence a
little bit of humor a little bit of UN
sort of unsought
awkwardness like I think that's part of
it like just being a little bit awkward
a little bit of
um
sort of authenticity or whatever that is
like just sort of feeling like I think
maybe that that same thing if not really
fully chasing it or fully sort of
needing it
oddly enough is almost the pre you know
it's like to go through the door you
have to not want to go through the door
too much I don't know if that's even
that's definitely not a saying and it
doesn't actually make any sense but
whatever sense you can make of that
contradictory statement if you want it
too much
I think that there's there's then you
need to step back and think about quite
it's almost like then you're not ready
um grasshopper is that the does
grasshoppers up with this you're saying
Karate Kid yeah I think if I can talk if
I can call you a grasshopper Steve no
um you know it's like it's that feeling
of uh you know at the end of the day
um that's more important things in life
and
um I don't want to overdo I actually got
lost in my metaphor a bit but I think in
the end it's like those different
qualities of
of of of it's it's that complement of
qualities and then just luck but I don't
think luck really you is a quality but
alongside I'm now at the position where
having done my job for long enough it's
put me in a slight I think there's loads
of people who could be
uh whoever I am like occupy that
cultural place that I'm in but you know
and partly I've earned my plays here and
partly I've been
really lucky
but I think you know when you said
something earlier it also made me think
of another quality which is to do with
which isn't a negative thing which is
that you know that idea like you when
you were told you know when I was told
that oh you know Patrick one you know
he's quite Keen to do some sort of talk
format or some interview thing where
you're on TV and I just think like well
I'm not really sure
I I think one of my because it goes back
to what you were asking earlier about oh
what what is the downside of these
various qualities like I do think
there's a term anhedonic have you ever
heard that term it just means I think
it's a clinical term but it sort of it
sort of means averse to pleasure or
lacking in pleasure like there's a part
of me again that
um I think my wife has helped me with is
that I I kind of sense that I'm not
always connected to pleasure does that
sound weird like I I you know sometimes
I I sort of drift through life and and I
have to sort of stop and remind myself I
think because I sort of
I tend to see downsides and I'm working
on that and I really do like I I sort of
need to
it's really odd like
I've won three baftas not bragging uh
this just came up and I and I mentioned
it's a fact and um and when you win a
bafta
you've got a lot of awards up there I'm
not seeing a bafta maybe those are just
I presented them after to someone else
some of them one's a camera I'm not sure
that camera is an award or you can do a
cutaway of that later you know it's odd
like I my main thing on winning each
time I won a bafta
I first always been oh [ __ ] now I have
to give an acceptance speech right and
have to get up there and um you know in
Hindi like the pleasure you get a little
pleasure over the subsequent years when
you can bring it up again and again as I
like to do but actually it's really odd
like I I most of the time when I get
good news sometimes I don't even
I can't notice the good news does that
sound really weird no that makes sense I
don't have that thank you for saying
that I think you're being polite yeah
I'm not someone who I'm not someone who
um
is who automatically feels connected to
the good things that happen to them
how does one remain happy if they have
that kind of default uh oh my God where
am I going to put this third bafta that
I've won or no it's awful but you just
sort of follow your routine you know and
actually I am a happy person and um
I um
I you know I I take pleasure in the
simple things in life you know I I like
um doing stuff with the you know stuff
with the family or you know really I
really am a gay son terrible I've met a
simple place like I like watching match
of the day at the weekend like you say
no yeah okay lots of people like doing
that what's that but you know like that
that for me
is one of the small things in the week
where I'm like I know I'm going to be
happy for the next 45 minutes or hour
you know what I mean or on on a Saturday
night I listen to loose ends on radio 4.
and often I'll be cooking and and that's
a small thing and I get a little
a little tiny little boost out of I know
I'm going to enjoy it but usually I
enjoy listening to it this little thing
I I mean
I I'm not if someone says like you're
gonna go on holiday to the Bahamas
you know I'm trying to imagine what a
really big happy thing would be I would
normally experience that as Stress and
Anxiety I think that's quite normal
though holidays are stressful aren't
they maybe you've got your priorities in
order in fact because you don't seem to
be compelled or
um or derive your happiness from like
the big wanky stuff from like the
Lamborghini the Bugatti the bafta yeah
what color is your Bugatti the GQ Man of
the Year stuff you simply seem to drive
it from the the simple intrinsically
fulfilling things like you know cooking
listening to a thing that's
intellectually stimulating so maybe
we're all like maybe everyone else is a
weirdo and you're actually incredibly
normal I don't know I think there's more
of us out there
than you might think but maybe not
we're all trapped in our own brains
there's no way of measuring I do think
that um you know I mentioned that when I
saw that I got a nice review in the
times that gave me like as I said I gave
me a buzz you cared about your work
there you really cared about well that
wasn't even about I mean I do care about
the work I mean work is a big source of
pleasure like in the sense of either
being on location and
um being aware of it going well and
getting into an almost like a mindset in
an interview of feeling like yeah this
is all good like I feel connected I feel
uh because it's a High Street in a way
I'm sure you have a little bit if you
have an interview with someone you feel
like you've been trying to book it for a
while
uh the moment comes you like the next
two hours are really important you want
it to go smoothly you want it to feel
like a revealing encounter you you want
to be probing and insightful and
attentive and immersed and not
distracted but also thinking ahead and
and all of that's going on and then it
starts and then you feel like oh it's
going okay and then afterwards you're
like that was a good one and then in the
edit you're putting it together and
you're piecing things in like that all
of those The Simple Pleasures of of
craft you know like it's really and it
is simple like it's no great mystery but
that that's that's a big part of um
of how I connect with
uh well my own happiness how do you
connect with people it's actually I
wanted to ask you this for my own sort
of learning you've done this for
multiple decades you've sat with people
from every corner of the world you have
all of these different experiences and
some of them are a little bit you know
the nicer sense a little bit out there
I'm glad I landed with a PC word yeah a
little bit out there I wonder what the
non-pc was
but you have um it was funny when I
asked you about the qualities you have I
think you absolutely nailed it and all
of those make you incredibly disarming
that almost like lack of intense
seriousness makes you a really disarming
individual
um
how do you connect with people how
intentional is your approach to
connecting with them in your new
interview series but also just generally
some of it is stuff that
you know I didn't I just sort of came by
by accident probably most of it which is
a thing you know Natural Curiosity which
I think you have a feeling of um
of just
just wanting to know what why people do
the things that they do right and and
sort of getting out of your own way a
bit you know in the sense because I
the question I get asked most often is
like what how do you
not get angry with some of these people
especially the ones who are sort of
spewing hate or coming out with stuff
that's really objectionable
I find it a slightly confusing question
because I think that's so it's so far
from what's in my head most of the time
I'm genuinely thinking like why
if it is someone like say a Neo-Nazi or
someone in Malton religious intolerance
I'm just so curious about what takes
someone
to that place what what's in their mind
that to actually berate them
to give them a hard time
or even be particularly journalistically
confrontational that's not that's not my
default mode it's so interesting because
I just think inject life generally those
who like seek to one even on our
personal relationships and romantic
relationships those that seek to
understand
to build Bridges but if you seek to like
as you say berate yeah I get told off on
this podcast a lot on like Twitter and
in the Press like because I don't berate
people like when I had Matt Hancock here
I asked him the questions I really
wanted to know but I didn't I didn't
come to berate him no he would have gone
yeah the war would have gone up had I
done that there's other ways of and some
people use a confrontational approach
and that's fine and then I think in
general
um you know there's many ways of doing
interviews
and I think probably
you know I haven't interviewed many
politicians and it's probably related to
that the feeling that they they have
their they tend to have their guard up
they tend to be
uh follow a strategy of attempting to be
as risk averse
headline averse as possible and it's
like those aren't the people I'm
interested in people who are genuinely
attempt who feel like they've got
something figured out or or are involved
in a in a world or a lifestyle or just
some situation that is
is either self-sabotaging or filled with
angst so in the end I see it as
not I'm not trying to get one over on
people I'm not trying to I honestly most
interviews I see as a as a potential
win-win you know what I mean like I I
should think like well there's no
there's no reason why you shouldn't tell
me the truth
um
you're involved in something that you're
relatively open about and
and I'll just assume that that's
probably the case now
obviously you're briefed you've done as
much research as you can but um
I think if you feel as though you're
coming from a position of
um sort of shared inquiry then that's
contagious
um I think also
I sort of tend to think I think there's
some part of me thinks maybe the other
person's got it figured out and I
haven't right a level of humility
so that when they say stuff I'm
genuinely thinking like well I guess
maybe or may or they say something
Bonkers I'm like well that isn't right
but I enjoy bumping up against that and
I don't go in there thinking I'm gonna
I'm gonna get this person like I'm gonna
get one over on them I sort of feel as
though you know you come in and you just
sort of try and
see what's going on you know if people
see like your
your temperature wrestle intimacies from
them that's never going to go well you
just create the space and the sense of
of understanding and allow them to sort
of walk through that
everything you've just described there
about creating the space to like
understand them the humility which is
ultimately creates that safety which
allows them to open up are the exact
things that I know my partner wants from
me in all of our interactions so because
you've got that skill in your work I'm
here assuming that you also have that at
home is that correct
um I think I could work better on it
like I'm very aware that the skill set I
often think about the skills that I have
in my work of being
supposedly a good listener and an
empathetic and and present person I
slightly fail at you know kind of I
think I'm very probably normal way in in
my relationship like I I have a very
happy marriage and probably you should
check that with Nancy uh because well
I'm slightly reviewing my own restaurant
if I can use that metaphor
um and um but yeah on Goodreads I gave
my book a five out of five and and you
know giving my marriage five out of five
uh so I think I think I could do I think
I could I could improve this episode is
brought to you by Mercedes-Benz who
recently got in touch to support the
diver CEO thank you I'm a huge fan of
their cars in fact I have one of my own
which is like an office on Wheels and
they have an exciting wide range of cars
that I'd love to tell you about the
Mercedes EQ is the luxury electric range
of Mercedes-Benz and it is available
across many models from the SUVs to the
saloons meaning they're ideal for all
business needs the Innovative Next
Generation technology found in all
Mercedes EQ cars is really Paving the
way for the electric car industry to
make your electric car switch so much
easier Mercedes-Benz has a service
called Mercedes me charge it's a
subscription which provides you with
access to a wide network of charging
stations across the entirety of the UK
the app shows you the precise location
and current availability and price at
the selected charging station of your
choice and this enables businesses to
effectively plan their route ahead of
their Journey you can search
Mercedes-Benz Fleet today to discover
how the Mercedes EQ car range can help
your business get ahead and if you
already drive a Mercedes EQ let me know
how you find it as some of you may know
Intel are now one of our sponsors on
this podcast and I really want to tell
you about that the pro platform which
has totally changed the game for my
businesses let me tell you why Intel V
Pro is built for businesses it offers
professional grade performance and the
most comprehensive security which is
something that is key for every
entrepreneur but the vpro platform also
offers complete modern management
capabilities which simply means that
it's perfect for a hybrid working setup
Intel has spent over 15 years developing
this technology with ecosystem partners
and I truly think it has the potential
to move businesses forward making your
business Journey far more productive and
efficient so I really encourage you to
go and find out more at
intel.co.ukvpro and let let me know what
you think because for me I know it's
added no end of benefit to all of our
systems and business continuity
topography on page 157
are you serious yes
gotta get through this
my life in strange times in television
do you know what I'm going to say Get it
On audiobook for an extra chapter about
Jimmy Savile that's true
speaking of page 157 and Jimmy Jimmy
Savile on that page your former wife
seeing as we're talking about
relationships and reviewing them Etc she
said there's nothing real about you yeah
and to the point of Jimmy Savile he also
said something which was to the same
vein about insincerity being your
specialty yeah
that's good I'm glad you brought that up
it's quite a
uh uh telling sort of ringing
piece of uh self-exposure where where
yeah I my wife and Jimmy Savile both
make the same critique of my
interpersonal qualities Finding Me
lacking in
basically authenticity lacking
insincerity there's nothing real about
well the first thing is when a
relationship is ending
um you seize whatever you can to hurt
the other person I think it's
I think
when someone you really love
and you think really loves you I mean I
it was my girlfriend at the time
although we were married and that's a
whole other
complicated but but yeah when that
relationship was ending
I think there's a feeling of betrayal
isn't there it's like I thought we were
we were together forever and I trusted
that that would be the case and and here
we are clearly you don't feel the same
way and and so I'm in the position of in
her eyes being
a Kind of Traitor and inauthentic
someone who didn't deliver
on
on what was promised although it wasn't
promised but what was what seemed to be
implicit
um
I think uh yeah incense I mean I
remember where we were like when the
Jimmy traveled the first documentary I
made about Jimmy Savile when he was
alive when Louis met Jimmy
not available on the iPlayer
um but it's on the internet you can find
it and um
I remember when we promoted it
um before I think it was when we
promoted it and he he agreed to do an
interview to promote it and he part of
that was a profile interview in the
guardian
and he was interviewed at the king's
cross in one of the in the hotel there
in one of the hotel rooms and the guy
from The Guardian came down I don't even
know why
I don't even know why it came up
um but I made a joke and he said ah
insincerity your specialty
gosh you asking me to get inside the
mind of Jimmy Savile to think about what
he meant when he criticized me I think
he thought that um
I think that journalistic role where um
well I think part I think you know what
it is is like
the best construct there's two
constructions I can put on that one is
just that
in journalism you sort of required to
inhabit this place of intimacy like
actually like hey let's do this and
let's do that and then afterwards
you sort of Disconnect and sometimes
that can feel jarring I don't think
actually that's what he meant though
like I think I think maybe in some cases
there's a there's a pop journalism that
can feel slightly
transactional where you're like let's
bro down on location and and have fun
and and yet if you looked at it
dispassionately it's slightly cynical
and calculating it's like well you're
doing this for a TV program
and and so there's a pilot slightly feel
a little bit uncomfortable I think
really what he was talking about there
was a sense of humor
um he was he was calling out
my sense of humor which is sometimes an
aspect of it which sometimes involves um
almost self-parody like an element of
where you say something
uh
almost
as a way of so parodying or satirizing
your own this isn't going to make any
sense to you but you said arise Your Own
Worst impulses like the best example I
can give
is when I said to um when I was with
Neil and Christine Hamilton right I did
a program and they were accused of
sexual assault and and while I filmed
with them and then I uh and they'll
become media circus and I carried on
filming and then they did a deal with
the mail on Sunday
to sell their story and I was
interviewing them during all of this and
I said to Christine
how how much did the mail on Sunday pay
for you uh for the interview I was just
curious because I knew probably they got
10 or 15 or 20 000 pounds and I was just
curious
and Christine said I'm not going to tell
you
and I said to Christine Christine this
is me I'm not a journalist I'm a friend
like you can tell me and a lot of people
gave me [ __ ] for it right like that what
I said but in my mind like that was a
funny thing to say because quite
obviously
um I am a journalist and whether I'm a
friend or not is actually not
established I'm not clearly not a friend
but I'm not also clearly a friend right
so that was kind of a funny remark
because I was being nakedly insincere
which is fun like sometimes to me what's
funny is saying
like not like so saying the wrong thing
saying the thing that's sort of brazen
as a way of
of just sort of identifying
the hypocrisy and having fun with it so
I tend to think that I think that's what
Jimmy Savile meant was that sometimes I
would say things that would kind of
definitively either untrue or quite
clearly
being said because they were not clearly
true anyway that's way you asked that
question and when you ask a question
about Jimmy Savile I'm going to give you
a long answer because it's easy to be
misconstrued but I think that's what he
meant I think I'm in general like fairly
um
a fairly straight up
person but I also think that the
tendency to believe your own [ __ ] to
drink your own Kool-Aid is is almost
Universal almost a precondition of life
right you know Nietzsche the German
philosopher
uh who I try not to quote too much
because it makes me sound pretentious
but he has he has a couple of really
good quotes on this where
one is um
for the true deceiver you know for the
most effective deceiver first he must
believe his own deceptions as a mangling
that quotation but the idea that in
order to con someone you sort of have to
believe the most effective con artist is
the one who believes their own con you
know
you and you know like a or a Seducer
like they say that about Casanova you
know one of the most um
notorious womanizers in human history
and they say that he actually each time
he seduced someone he fell in love with
them you know maybe it's true for sales
in general like you really gotta but if
you believe in that and and so I'm fully
aware that for me to say like I'm an
authentic human being and that my
journalism relies on a kind of true
connection I'm I you know there's a
little apartment things like I think I
believe that I'm pretty sure I I pre I
know I do believe that but I'm not my
own best reference on whether or not
that's really the case
I neglected my personal life to focus on
achieving some sort of professional
success the price of my lack of
emotional mouse was paid by those
nearest and dearest to me when did you
get that feedback because I remember the
times in my life where I've got that
feedback from
friends family romantic partners and at
first sometimes we sometimes argue
against it we oh [ __ ] off and then we
walk away and we go this is true I think
I've had that feedback
in my relationships more or less some
consistently
uh and and until maybe
[Music]
four or five six years ago like again I
feel like I'm reviewing my own book like
and now folks
I am happy and healthy and well adjusted
and I've arrived at a spiritual
place of Tranquility but I do I am
conscious that I um
all through my 20s and 30s I saw my
relationships as a um
oh am I think I think the other phrase I
use is like I saw my relationships as a
life support system for my
kind of work self do you know what I
mean amen instead of the other way
around you know and so I would say like
well I would take off when I went to
work for Michael Moore it was even back
in in the 90s it was a source of
friction in the relationship that like
without much warning because I became
the fill-in guy who when other state
people couldn't do segments or because
they were they found it weren't
available weren't stressed about it I
I'd be like let's get Louis to do it I I
did a lot of great segments just by
being available at a moment's notice to
fly somewhere and and never thought
really which I don't know that that it
was the wrong thing to do at that time
we didn't have kids
um
and so I'd be like okay I'm off for
three or four days
and um but as it went on and then as I
had kids
um and I was still doing the same thing
sort of saying to my wife well this is
what I do there's a chapter in my book
called this is what I do
you know you knew when we married that
we would be um that I was a sort of
globetrotting TV documentary maker and
she um
she said yeah what did I do when we when
we met I was a TV director as well and
I've changed what I do and you need to
change what you do like I don't mean to
sound like she was being horrible about
it but her attitude was like people make
a you need to make an adjustment to
accommodate the fact that we now have
two small children and how did you
receive that
um at first
I think I received that as
well not not well like it didn't make me
angry but I I was somewhat inflexible
because my attitude was look I was
because I went you know my parents had
it my dad traveled a lot for work my mum
was a full-time TV producer and we had
people at home
Opeth who um who made sure that when we
got home someone was there and would
make us a meal and so I was like well we
just need to get help she said I don't
want I don't want
us to get help I said she she said well
I said I said you can do whatever you
want to do you you can carry on working
five days a week six days you can travel
as well if you want we just need to get
help and she's I don't I want one of us
to be here and I want for some of that I
want it to be you I don't know does that
sound so you sound like me really yeah
yeah and I was like well
I said I guess I don't see it that way
so it became a bit of an impasse for a
while and then and then um
well then we had another child
and
um
and she said well now we've got a baby
and two small children
and you've agreed to take to make sure
you only work in the UK
and I was like did I agree to that he
said yes and I couldn't remember it but
I was like well she's probably right and
um did you make rules I read that you
made some rules you had a rule that I
wouldn't go away for more than two weeks
and um
and actually for most of the time
it was between sort of a week and 10 or
12 days are you flexible now I don't
want to make my wife sound like I know
there's some people might hear that go
like well
you know Louis was obviously bringing
back the bigger wage and and so he
should have been I I honestly think my
wife
was right about most of that
I feel the same way about my partner and
it's almost identical that it it took me
to find the right person to compromise
my inflexibility where they they made
the case to me that quality time and
this relationship was actually an equal
priority let's say to the work and with
the right person I was finally willing
to bend and I was finally willing to you
know so but I think it takes the right
person yeah for me it does anyway yeah
the right person the right relationship
the right life stage yeah I also say
that these interviews I'm doing part of
that is an agreement that we made well
even in agreement a kind of agreement I
made with myself in lockdown and being
around my kids are now 16 14 and 8. you
know it turns out older children in many
respects
you need more management need more sort
of Parental presence in their lives than
younger children and so I said well
maybe a way for me to travel less and
not be taking off for you know two or
three months a year because you
aggregate those two week trips or Teddy
and they add up to maybe a quarter or a
third of the year and now I I can I can
my schedule is much more I said if I do
these interviews and we make TV shows in
the UK and that there's a more
controllable schedule and I can be
around more Nancy helped me set up the
company she's working more I'm home more
and so it's actually like it turns out
conforming to those
expectations of family involvement is
really positive like it can actually be
a creative
Boone you know it's not the enemy
necessarily it can be it can make you a
more rounded person that ends up being
beneficial
that's exactly what I used to think it
was I used to think it was the enemy of
my professional success but I've come to
learn it's the yeah it serves it
um you mentioned anxiety throughout this
conversation now sometimes when people
talk about anxiety they talk about it as
in
um
like like an emotion they kind of it's a
flippant word to describe a situation
where you're thinking a little bit much
but then there's what people would
describe as sort of real anxiety that
kind of crippling like oh you know that
we've all felt that it's like insane
unshakable and sort of deep nervousness
about situation and worry which one are
you referring to uh I think the first
one I I don't think I've ever had a
panic attack for example
um I don't think I've ever had a feeling
of um
kind of in being incapacitated I mean
I've had moments where I've had stage
fright or Mom you know that that thing
where
due to you just get a even recently like
there's been moments where
you just get this sort of tremulous
feeling of nerves and your voice starts
to shake have you ever had that well
you've been in a situation where
or sometimes it's just sometimes it's to
do with your inner
you get into an argument with someone
and you get really upset and your voice
goes a bit like this like it doesn't you
know it was just kind of horrible or
sometimes it's just where you feel like
you're you're like I've been once or
twice in in situations where um
I just think oh this isn't going well
and then your confidence goes I mean if
that's quite that's the sort of nerves
which is slightly different from anxiety
anxiety like where but the anxiety I
mainly mean is just a kind of sense of
foreboding a pervasive feeling of
um of worry about something that's going
to happen
because one of the things we talk a lot
about on this podcast is about mental
health and about how that affects people
that are in high profile high stress
positions what's your you know mental
health is a topic that kind of emerged
in cultural relevance about maybe a
decade ago now but when I was a kid I
didn't understand it I didn't know what
that was and I I'll be honest I think
the stigma was very much my belief it
was kind of like people across some
people are crazy yeah
um what's your journey been like with
your own mental health I feel really
lucky to have
um broadly speaking good mental health I
also think what you're saying is exactly
right and I think that there's a kind of
there's a continuity a blurring that
exists so that um you think mental
health as opposed to mental illness is a
good way of thinking about it like that
because actually
um we should all be striving towards
being our best selves we should be
managing our anxiety I think a lot of
men especially fail even to recognize
when their mental health may not be as
good as it could be
and the extreme end you've got
incapacitating mental illness that
requires a set of interventions possibly
medication
even sort of residential rehab settings
but for for the rest of us it's just
it's keeping an eye on
on how you're doing and and no you know
sometimes I notice my emotions from the
outside like I noticed that my voice is
raised I'm like wow I'm angry you know
like or or and even when I'm sad I or
grumpy or whatever it is
I'm not the first really to see it or my
wife will say like are you in a bad
place I think we've been guilty of
failing to see mental health as a
holistic condition like in other words
that your support network needs to be in
place you need social inter these are
really basic but you need social
interaction you need you need
um exposure to things outside of work
you also need endorsement and approval
in work and all of these things need to
be sort of pulling in the same direction
there may be people in your life who are
undermining you and you may need support
from people to nudge you in the right
direction but you know not to sound
really Bland about it I feel as though
I've
um
you know through sort of my wife's
perceptiveness and her ability to sort
of see how how just so involved me in
life a bit more
that that's um that's kept me in a good
place
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast which um
which is the previous guest writes a
question for the next guest wow okay and
the previous guest you don't get to know
who the previous guest was but the
previous guest has written a question
um for you not knowing it was for you
and they said what is your opinion
on hallucigens
hallucinogens
um I my opinion is
I think
um
you know if you're if you feel like
you're if you're of age like 18 plus I
don't know how your younger listeners
are you know maybe it may be slightly
older
um and you feel like you've got solid
mental health I think it's a it's not a
bad Avenue to go down it's not something
I've
massively dabbled in
um I've noticed I don't know about you
like in my social settings
um it seemed to be mushroom oil it's
something that's increasingly
being used uh and I think actually in
you know you know and I think we're all
aware of the slight
there's a dissonance between our levels
of acceptance of alcohol and then the
sort of relative unacceptance of things
like whether it's marijuana or mushrooms
and mushroom oil like I'd like to see
that leveled out like I'd like to see as
it is in California and elsewhere I'd
like to see cannabis legalized and
um I think mushroom oil
without giving too much away could be
really positive
from what I understand Louis thank you
so much for your time today thank you so
much from you for so many reasons um and
your new documentary on the BBC BBC Two
and on iPlayer Louis through interviews
is incredible yeah um six them out there
right now
um they're incredible and you're
interviewing some incredible people that
are are being very vulnerable and open
with you but thank you for the
inspiration as well you're someone that
I've watched for the for decades so
Steve that's given me a life full of
enjoyments and thank you for coming and
doing this pleasure
quick one right now one of my sponsors
on this podcast who I absolutely adore
crafted the men's jewelry brand are
having a sale right now up to 70 percent
off a brand that's already incredibly
affordable if you ever see me wearing
jewelry on videos in real life it's
crafted jewelry this particular piece
these pearls here are one of my favorite
pieces to wear when I'm trying to wear a
fashionable item all of their pieces I
wear all of their rings I wear all of
their jewelry and I did before they
sponsored this podcast I actually asked
them to sponsor this podcast because I
was such a big fan of the brand I'm not
somebody that rolls around in Rolexes
and stuff like that but I do want
quality jewelry that isn't going to
change color that is going to be durable
enough to keep up with me
um that looks fashionable and that has a
sense of meaning and that's exactly what
crafted has in their rings in their
necklaces in everything they produce I
know the founders I know how much they
care and if you're a man that often
struggles to find a good place to to buy
good quality jewelry that's not going to
change color that's not going to break
crafted is the answer and it's
incredibly incredibly affordable and
they have a sale on right now which they
never ever do 70 off I implore you to go
and check it out for many years people
have been asking for a coffee flavored
Hill and quite recently he'll release
the iced coffee caramel flavor of their
um ready to drink Hills and I've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
Jules ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about you
[Music]
foreign